[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF BROWN: One of
the first things
I want to do before we get
into the presentation proper
is I want to
demonstrate something
that I'm going to quickly
introduce it right now.
And then towards the
end of this session,
we're going to circle
back around and make
more sense of it.
But there are some
reasons that I'll
clarify later that I want
to kick this off right now.
And if we can switch
to the demo machine
briefly that would help me out.
All right.
So as I said, I'm going
to demonstrate something
really quickly that's only going
to make a little bit of sense
right now and
we're going to make
more sense before we're done.
But I've got a couple of
microservices running out
on GCP right now.
And notice that URL there
begins with mn-backend.
So I'm sending a request
to this backend service.
And I'm sending a
request to slash
hello slash Jeff is
all that's really
important about that URL--
slash hello slash Jeff.
And we get back a response
that is what you see there--
Hello space Jeff.
That doesn't look
terribly interesting.
But there are a number of
interesting things going on
that we'll get to.
So when I send a request
to the backend service
at slash hello slash
Jeff, we got a response
like you see there.
And if I send a similar request
to another service called
the frontend service,
what we're going to see
is a similar response, but the
response is all upper case.
And we've got in place is there
are two microservices deployed
to GCP right now.
One is the backend service,
one is the frontend service.
The backend service
knows how to create
this greeting, hello Jeff.
The frontend service is
calling the back end service
and converting the
message to uppercase,
just we've got something
happening in the frontend
service.
That's really all I want to get
into around what those services
are capable of right now.
But what I want to
do while I'm pressing
into the rest of
the talk is I want
to deploy a new version
of this backend service.
And that's going
to allow me to talk
about some interesting
capabilities
that I think you'll
find interesting.
So I've just made a code change
to our backend controller.
There where a moment ago
it said, hello plus name.
This is the service we're
invoking from the command line.
I'm going to make a
code change and instead
of saying hello Jeff, it'll say
Google Next says, hello Jeff.
And I want to deploy
that service to GCP.
App engine deploy,
just like that.
And I'll let that get far
enough along that I know
that I don't have a typo there.
That looks good.
OK.
So while that's running, if we
can go back to the slides now?
I appreciate the help.
We're going to come
back to that and talk
about a number of interesting
things going on there.
All right.
So my name is Jeff Brown.
I am a partner at
Object Computing,
and I'm one of the co-founders
of a couple of open source
frameworks that we
develop and support.
One of them is the
Grails framework,
which is a JVM web
framework that's
been around for over
a decade and has
been tremendously successful.
And we're very proud of that.
And I'm also the co-founder
of another technology called
Micronaut, which
I'm going to spend
more time talking about today.
I help run the
Grails and Micronaut
practice at Object Computing.
And you see some contact
information there.
I'm easy enough to track down
if you want to get a hold of me.
And speaking of
getting a hold of me,
we do have a booth set up
out here in the exhibit hall.
The booth number is on
the very last slide,
so that'll be easy enough
for you to find later.
I believe it's 1163.
Please stop by the
booth and talk to us
if you have any questions
at all about what
I'm going to introduce today
or anything at all that we
can help you with.
All right.
So Object Computing
is headquartered
in St. Louis, Missouri, which
is where I happen to live.
We are a distributed team.
We've got folks all over
the country and elsewhere.
We've got a number of folks
in Europe and Australia.
But our headquarters
is in St. Louis.
And as I said, that's
where I happen to live.
Object Computing has been in
business for about 25 years
and has been an open source
company since the very
beginning, which is
really interesting in part
because in the mid-'90s there
were not very many open source
companies.
And object computing
was one of them.
We heard some great
talk this morning
during the keynote about
Google's commitment
to open source.
And I'll get back to
that point a little bit
later in the presentation.
But we've done some
really interesting things
with Google that relates to
our open source software.
And I'll get to that.
So Object Computing is the
home to both the Grails
and Micronaut team.
It's really one big team.
We don't have two separate
teams managing these two
technologies.
It's one team of engineers.
And as I said, I'm the
practice lead there
at Object Computing helping
manage all of those efforts.
We've got deep expertise in a
number of areas, some of them
that you see listed there--
Industrial IoT,
machine learning,
blockchain consulting,
and cloud engineering.
And we're going to find that--
most of you are probably aware--
that Google is a great
fit, GCP in particular
is a great fit for building
these kinds of applications.
And Micronaut is
a really great fit
for building these
kinds of applications
and deploying them to GCP.
And I'm going to spend
some time this morning
pressing into some details
that will support all of that
and help that make more sense.
This is a partial
list of clients
at Object Computing
some of these names
we saw earlier
during the keynote.
Some of these companies
are large Google users.
One of the interesting things
about this partial client list
is notice that it spans
really a lot of industries.
We've got the semiconductors,
telecommunications, finance,
aerospace.
So Object Computing has
served many industries
over the last 25 years.
And it turns out that's
a great fit for what
I want to talk about today
because Micronaut and GCP,
these are not technologies
for aerospace.
And they're not technologies
for telecommunications.
They're general
purpose technologies
that can be used everywhere.
And that's just one more reason
that our technology and GCP
is such a great fit together.
And by the way, I cannot
see past the first few rows
in a room this big.
So raising your
hand will not help.
I probably won't see your hand.
I'll try to make some
time for Q&A at the end.
And there are mics here where
we'll take those questions,
if we do have time.
But as I said at the
beginning, if you've
got any questions at all that
we don't get to get to today,
please come by the
booth and see us.
I intended to
mention that earlier.
I apologize for that.
All right.
So I mentioned
just really, really
quickly, I want to talk a little
bit about the Grails framework.
And then I want to get
into Micronaut and GCP.
But talking just for a couple
of minutes about Grails
is going to help us make
sense of some of the stuff
that I want to press into.
So Grails is an open
source framework
for building web
applications for the JVM.
And it's been around
for over a decade.
In February of 2008, is
when we shipped Grails 1.0,
and the framework predates
1.0 by a year or so.
So the framework's been around
for 11 or 12 years, we'll say.
And it's been tremendously
successful over that time.
So we're very
proud of the Grails
framework and the business
that we have built around that.
One of the things that
has enabled Grails
to be as relevant
and as important
as it's been for as long as it
has been, for over a decade,
is the fact that the technology
has evolved considerably
since the beginning to
stay relevant to the way
that folks want to build
applications today.
So in 2007, when we started
all of this certainly
the idea of REST existed.
But it was nowhere near as
big of a deal as it is today.
Every enterprise builds
REST services today.
And so in the very
beginning, there
wasn't a whole lot
of support for REST
in the Grails framework.
You could certainly build
REST services with Grails,
but there wasn't a whole
lot of support for building
those kinds of apps.
And over the years as REST
got more and more important,
Grails stayed ahead of
that by adapting to the way
that people want to
build applications.
So over the years, we
built more and more support
for publishing REST services.
And today we have really, really
terrific support in Grails
for building REST services.
And that's an example of
the technology evolving
over the years to stay relevant.
And that's an important part
of the technology's longevity.
GORM falls in that
same category.
GORM is the ORM tool
that's part of Grails
and it's always
been part of Grails.
It's been part of Grails
since the very beginning.
In the very beginning,
GORM was conceived
to be a layer on
top of Hibernate.
We added a bunch of really
cool and powerful capabilities
on top of Hibernate
and made it easier
to take advantage of what
Hibernate had to offer.
But that's what GORM was
in the very beginning.
And then over the years, GORM
has evolved to adapt to the way
that people want to use
the technology like GORM.
So for example, early
on we introduced
JPA support so you could
pull out Hibernate and plug
into whatever JPA
implementation you like.
And then fast
forward a few years
past that and the
so-called noSQL databases
started gaining a lot of
traction and momentum--
databases like
MongoDB and Cassandra.
And there were a
whole bunch of those.
People wanted to
use GORM to talk
to those kinds of database.
So we evolved GORM further.
And today we've got GORM
implementations for Hibernate
and JPA and MongoDB
and Neo4j, which
is a really interesting
graph database, Cassandra.
We've got a bunch of
GORM implementations.
The point there is
that the technology
has evolved to stay
relevant and to keep itself
an important part of
the landscape in which
these technologies play.
So as we're confronted with
changes in the landscape,
the technology changes
to deal with those.
And now today and
in recent years,
one of the changes that we've
had to confront and come up
with solutions for--
a whole category of challenges--
is microservices.
When we first started
building Grails a decade ago,
monoliths were the way that
most folks built and deployed
JVM web applications.
You put your whole application
in one big WAR file, drop
that WAR filed in Tomcat or
whatever server container
you prefer, and that's how
you deploy web applications.
And if any part of
that application
needs to be updated, you have
to update the whole thing.
And there are benefits to
a monolithic architecture
like that.
There are drawbacks to a
monolithic architecture
like that.
But that's how applications,
by and large, were built.
And those are the
kinds of applications
that Grails was initially
designed for and prioritized
for.
Now, as more and
more enterprises
want to build microservice
architectures,
there's a whole
suite of challenges
that come along with building
those kinds of systems.
And that's another example
of changes in the landscape
that our technology
needs to adapt to.
So we recognize those
changes, those new challenges.
Google recognizes
those challenges.
And you recognize
those challenges,
or you will as you start
looking into migrating
to microservice architectures.
There are lots of good
reasons to deploy applications
in that kind of architecture,
but all the benefits
don't come for free.
There are new
challenges that you'll
have to confront with
microservices that maybe you
didn't have to confront
with monoliths.
And what we're
doing with Micronaut
and our integrations
with GCP is we're
trying to make it as easy as
possible for folks to build
those kinds of systems and
take advantage of these really
robust services that
Google has to offer
with minimal burden on the
application development team,
and minimal complexity in
the application code base.
So we recognized a whole
new set of challenges
that relate to
microservices, and we
had to decide what
to do about that.
So when we wanted
to evolve GORM,
we realized, hey, we've got
this great tool for dealing
with relational databases.
People want to use
that tool to talk
to non-relational databases,
and we figured out
how to evolve the technology
to deal with that.
With microservices that
was one of our options.
One of the things we
could have done was
continue to evolve
our current technology
to be more and more
compatible with
microservice architectures.
That that's one approach
we could have taken.
We decided not to
take that approach.
Rather than evolve
our current technology
to be a better fit for
microservices, what we decided
to do was design
a whole new thing
from the ground up specifically
designed for microservices
and specifically prioritizing
microservice architectures.
And that's what Micronaut is.
Micronaut is an open
source framework
for building microservice
applications for the JVM.
It's been designed and optimized
specifically for microservices.
So certainly you can build
monoliths with Micronaut
and people will
do that and people
will have success with that.
But we're designing and
optimizing the framework
specifically for
microservice architectures.
The runtime is very lightweight.
It's based on Netty, which
offers a bunch of really
positive characteristics.
It's really fast.
It's really lightweight.
It's got a bunch of really
great reactive support
in the framework that
we're taking advantage
of at the Micronaut level.
So the runtime in Micronaut
is based on Netty.
And as I said, it's really,
really fast and really,
really lightweight.
We'll come back to that
point a little bit later.
Micronaut is a
polyglot framework.
So the languages that we've got
proper support for in Micronaut
include Java,
Kotlin, and Groovy.
And all of our annotation
processing that we--
so all the annotations that
we support in Micronaut work
across all three
of those languages.
The exact same annotations.
They all yield the
same net effects.
So if you would prefer to
build your systems with Kotlin
and you prefer to take
advantage of all the benefits
that Kotlin has
to offer, you can
do that and take
advantage of everything
that Micronaut has to offer.
If you prefer dynamic
languages like Groovy,
we've got terrific
support for doing that.
If you're a Java
shop and don't want
to introduce any of these
other non-Java JVM languages,
you can build your
whole systems with Java.
And the languages can mix
and match within a project.
So within a single
Micronaut service,
you can have Java code and
Kotlin code and Groovy code
and it all just plays well
together really, really well.
So it's a polyglot
framework for the JVM.
Micronaut is really
not just one thing.
It's really a whole
portfolio of things.
And that portfolio of things
includes some components
like an aspect
oriented programming
engine, and a
dependency injection
container, and an HTTP client.
And a number of these
components can be used separate
from the rest of Micronaut.
So for example, our
dependency injection container
that we've built in Micronaut
has some really interesting
innovative characteristics
to it that I'll talk about.
But that DI container
is usable separate
from the rest of Micronaut.
So if you're building
a Java application
and you want a DI
container, you can
use Micronaut's DI container
in that job application
without using any of
our HTTP server stuff,
or without using any of the
other components that are part
of Micronaut, which is great.
Some of the interesting
characteristics
of our dependency
injection container
all have to do with the fact
that our DI container doesn't
do any runtime reflection,
which, it turns out,
is a really big deal.
One of the reasons that our
current technology before we
built Micronaut--
so Grails in particular-- one of
the reasons that Grails is not
a terrific fit for
building microservices
has to do with Grails dependence
on the Spring framework.
And the Spring
framework is terrific.
There's all kinds of
really, really great stuff
that Spring does, and
those are the reasons
that we built Grails on
the Spring framework.
But Spring is
expensive in some ways,
for certain kinds
of applications.
And a lot of that has to
do with Spring's dependence
on runtime reflection
and dynamic proxies.
So what we've done
with Micronaut
is we've eliminated all the
runtime reflection and all
the runtime proxies
and replaced that
with a really sophisticated,
ahead of time compilation
compile time tricks to do all
the stuff that we otherwise
would have done with
reflection at runtime.
So all of our
annotation processing
is all configured
at compile time.
Our whole dependency
injection container
is all configured
at compile time.
No runtime proxies,
no runtime reflection.
And that is where a lot of
our performance benefits
are coming from in
Micronaut and where
a lot of other positive aspects
like much smaller memory
footprints.
So we'll talk a little bit
more about that as we press on.
As I said, Micronaut is
being designed and optimized
specifically for
building microservices.
And in a microservice
architecture,
you don't have one thing, you
have numerous things, and maybe
lots of things.
You have this whole
architecture of components
communicating with each other.
So a request comes into the
system and hits component
A, and component A
calls component B,
and component B
calls component C.
And that's how these
microservice architectures
work.
In each one of
those interactions,
you've got a client
and a server.
When A calls B, A is a
client and B is a server.
And when B calls C, B
becomes a client and C
is the server for that
particular communication.
Because that's the way
microserver architectures work,
Micronaut prioritizes both
sides of those communications.
So we've got a really, really
sophisticated HTTP client,
as well as a bunch of really
cool and powerful server side
stuff.
And we'll look at
examples of both of those.
Some of the priorities
that the framework has
include things like
developer productivity.
Time to market is really
important and really valuable,
and we recognize that.
So we make a lot of design
decisions specifically targeted
at contributing to
developer productivity.
And another attribute
that goes along with that
is code simplicity.
In a Micronaut
application you're
going to write considerably
less code than you
might with other frameworks.
And all that is related to
not only time to market,
but ease of maintaining and
extending the system over time.
So we prioritize developer
productivity and code
simplicity while embracing a
familiar programming model.
So folks who are used
to building applications
with modern JVM
web frameworks will
see a lot of the
same kinds of idioms
show up in a
Micronaut application.
So for example, you can
write a service class
and annotate that service
class with at transactional
and a bunch of really cool and
powerful transaction management
related stuff will be
associated with that class.
What I just now described isn't
new, and isn't innovative.
Those capabilities have
been around for a long time.
But how we're doing that
is new and innovative.
And again, that has to do
with all of our compile time
annotation processing
stuff, which
allows us to rig up things
like the DI container
all at compile time and not
rely on any runtime reflection
or runtime practices.
And a particularly
important part
of all of this that we
want to focus on today
is our ease of integration
with these really, really
sophisticated enterprise
scale type cloud services.
So if you're going to build
a microservice architecture
and deploy it to
GCP, you're probably
going to want to take advantage
of things like CloudSQL
and Kubernetes and all
of these robust services
that Google has provided.
One of the things that
Micronaut is doing
is making it very, very
easy to take advantage
of those services without having
to take on much of the burden
or the cost associated with--
the development
burdens associated
with building systems that take
advantage of those services.
And the framework is
really, really fast.
Runtime performance
is another one
of the things that's an
important attribute that
effects all of our
design decisions.
So we want you to be able
to build the thing quickly.
We want it to be a simple,
easy to maintain, and easy
to extend code.
We want you to be
able to integrate
with these robust suite of cloud
services that are out there.
And we need the thing to be
really, really fast at runtime.
And in fact, it is.
So some of the
important benefits
that Micronaut has to offer
include runtime performance
that shows up in terms of
startup time for your services,
as well as performance while
the application is running.
So a typical Micronaut service
can be started up in something
like a second.
Sometimes less than a second,
sometimes a little bit more.
It depends on what the
application is doing.
But a second puts you
in the neighborhood.
It's not like 20 seconds or
30 seconds or even 10 seconds.
One second startup time
puts you in the ballpark.
Minimal memory requirements.
So a small Micronaut
service can run
in about 10 megabytes
of heap, and depending
on what your
application is doing
will dictate how much
above that you need.
But that kind of
represents the overhead
or the tax associated
with the framework itself,
which is really,
really quite small.
We're not going to look a
whole lot of code here today,
but we'll see a
little bit of code.
But one of the attributes of
systems built with Micronaut
is the code really
is quite simple.
As I said before, we're
embracing familiar programming
models and enabling
easy integration
with Cloud Services.
So a small Micronaut JAR file
might be about 8 megabytes.
That's the size of the JAR file.
And of course, the more code
you put in your project,
the JAR profile is
going to get bigger.
But that, again,
represents the overhead
that the framework brings along
which is really quite small.
And you see the startup time and
heap requirement numbers there.
And I want to take just a
minute to talk a little bit
about these are attributes that
relate to microservices in ways
that they don't
necessarily relate
to monolithic applications.
So think about memory
consumption as an example.
If you're building a
monolithic application
and that application
requires a gig of RAM
to run, in your
development environment
you start the thing
up with Gradle
or whatever tool you're
using to start the app.
And you allocate a gig
of RAM to the thing,
or maybe the startup scripts
are doing that for you
and you don't even
really think about it.
But allocating a gig of
RAM to your monolithic app
may not be that big of a
deal because there's only one
of them.
In a microservice
architecture, there's
not going to be one of them.
There's going to be
maybe lots of them.
So if you've got a monolithic
servlet container based web app
and try to start, say 30
of those up concurrently
on your development machine.
And it's just not going to
work for a number of reasons.
And one of those
reasons is you're going
to run into memory issues.
In a microservice
architecture, you
might really want to do that.
You might want to start up
a whole bunch of services
on one machine in your
development environment.
So the memory requirements,
they factor into that equation
differently than they would
for a monolithic application.
And in your
deployment environment
on the cloud where you're
paying for VMs that
based on how many CPUs used and
how much RAM you're allocating
to them, adding up all of
those large memory requirement
machines in your cloud
environment can get expensive.
So these are examples
of attributes
that they affect your
microservice architectures
differently than they affect
monolithic applications.
So one of the things
that Micronaut does
is it makes it very, very
easy to take advantage
of these robust cloud services
that the cloud providers make
available.
So we've got really,
really great support
for service discovery
by way of Consul.
We've got support for Eureka.
We've got support
for Kubernetes.
So we support all the major
service discovery engines.
And again, this is an
example of a thing that's
important in a microservice
application that's
not important, or maybe
not even relevant at all
in the context of a
monolithic application.
In a monolith there's only
one, so there is no discovery.
You're not going out and trying
to find these other things
to communicate with.
So service discovery is
an example of a capability
that the framework
provides to make
it easy to take
advantage of something
like service
discovery that is part
of that new suite of challenges
that microservice architectures
bring along.
Configuration sharing is
kind of the same thing.
If you have lots of
microservices deployed out
in your cloud
environment, you probably
want them to share
configuration.
And we've built really,
really sophisticated systems
to make it easy
to take advantage
of distributed configuration
engines and all the major cloud
providers.
We've got some really
interesting client side load
balancing stuff built
into our HTTP client,
that if I've got some time
I'll be able to demonstrate
a little bit later.
We've got support for building
message driven applications.
We've got integrations with
technologies like Kafka.
We've got really great support
for serverless computing,
and a lot more.
So Micronaut is not
just a framework
for building REST services.
It's not just that.
It is that, but it's a
whole bunch more than that.
And a lot of that has to
do with all of these cloud
native capabilities
that we've built right
into the technology.
This quote here that
was posted on Twitter--
I believe this was
posted before we even
got to release 1.0, which we
released this past October--
this person recognized
something that--
what he's recognizing
is that one
of the things that
Micronaut is and does
is it enables you to very easily
build these systems to take
advantage of all these
services like Kafka
and Consul, and Zipkin,
and MongoDB, and JPA,
and on and on.
That's one of the
things that Micronaut
is, is it's an
accelerator for folks
who want to take advantage of
these robust cloud services
without having to spend lots
of time and development effort
building the integrations
with those systems.
So Google has been a
priority for the Micronaut
team at Object Computing really
pretty much the whole time
that we've been working on this.
But certainly right now
Google is a priority.
We've partnered with Google.
Object Computing as an
official Google partner.
And we've got really
great support in Micronaut
for taking advantage of
GCP Google Cloud Services.
So we've got support for
Kubernetes, and Stackdriver,
and gRPC, and there are others.
Some of these, Google's
actually contributed the support
to the framework.
So for example, this week we'll
be releasing Micronaut 1.1.
And in 1.1 we've
got some new support
for Stackdriver and gRPC.
And some of that was
developed by Google,
and they contributed those
efforts to the open source
software, which is fantastic.
And that's a little bit of
putting your money where
your mouth is with respect to
what Google said this morning
during the keynote.
Google says that they're
committed to open source,
and Google really is
committed to open source.
And this is one small
way that that manifests.
All right.
So I want to take a look
at a little bit of code,
and that'll help us
tease out some things
that I think you'll
find interesting.
So this could be a Java
class in a Micronaut service.
And we've got a controller.
What makes this
thing a controller
is it's annotated
with App Controller.
Those of you who might be
familiar with the Grails
framework might recognize
that in Grails we
have lots of
conventions in place
that do things like if you've
got a class whose name ends
in the word controller
it becomes a controller.
And those conventions
do not exist
in the Micronaut framework.
So what makes this a controller
is not the class name.
The class name
could be anything.
What makes it a controller
is it's annotated
with that controller.
And there's a method in
this controller that's
annotated with that at get.
So if I send and get requests
to slash hello, slash something
this controller
action gets executed.
And then I can do
whatever I need to do.
And there's a lot I can
do in this controller.
There's a bunch of interesting
data marshaling going on
in both directions for
reading and writing
the body of the request
and the response.
There's a bunch
of reactive stuff.
There's a whole lot you
can do on a controller.
This example is literally a
whole world kind of example.
But that's a
controller that could
be in a Micronaut service.
And in fact, the service
that I was interacting
with from the command
line at the very beginning
of the session looked
a whole lot like that.
So we've got this
backend application
that has a controller in it.
Then I might have
another service.
This is not in the
same application.
This is a whole
different service
that's part of our
microservice architecture.
This is the frontend.
So I've got a
backend piece that's
maybe talking to a database
and doing whatever it's doing.
And separate from that, I've
got another microservice
that is in the frontend.
And this thing wants to
call the backend service.
That's how microservice
architectures work.
You've got these components,
making calls to each other.
This is one microservice
making a call to another.
And the call is happening at
that last line of code there
where it says,
BackendClient.hello(name).
That's actually making an HTTP
call to some other service.
There are a number of
interesting things going on
in that method call,
and we're going
to be able to press into
just a little bit of that.
Notice that BackendClient that
we're interacting with there
was injected into
this controller
by way of dependency injection.
And so we've got
a constructor here
that accepts a backend
client as a parameter.
And at compile
time, Micronaut will
recognize that that
constructor is there
and create all the
instructions that it
takes to not only
create this thing,
but to pass the required
dependencies as constructor
parameters when it is created.
So the BackendClient is being
injected into this controller,
and that's one of the
things I want to look at.
And this is the BackendClient,
and this looks terribly benign.
There's really
nothing interesting
that's apparent from
looking at that source code.
It's not even a class.
It's just an interface
that has a method in it.
And there are a
couple of annotations.
As uninteresting as
the source code looks,
what's actually going
on is quite interesting.
So at compile time what
the framework is doing
is creating an instance--
creating a class that
implements this interface.
And in that class will
be a method called hello.
And when you call that
method, an HTTP request
will be made to some
remote service--
and we'll figure out
how we know about where
that remote services
before we're done.
But we're making an HTTP
call to some remote service
and passing--
so if I call hello and
pass Jeff as a parameter,
then the request will be sent
to slash hello, slash Jeff.
So we've made it very, very
easy to make an HTTP call.
But this is more than just that.
So when I annotated this
interface with at client,
that's what makes this
thing and HTTP client.
And the value that
I can specify there
can be one of a
number of things.
So where you see BackendURL
inside of the curly braces,
that's a variable.
It's a config variable.
So whatever the value
of Backend.URL is,
that'll be inserted
at this point.
So instead of using
a config variable,
I can put a URL there.
I can put and HTTPS://
and have a URL there.
And now when I make
calls to this method,
that URL represents where the
remote service is that I'll
be communicating with.
And there are other values
that that BackendURL can have.
But let's press on here.
So now I've got
some configuration
in the backend and the
frontend represented here.
Remember these are
two separate services,
two separate
applications we'll say.
In my development
environment I want
to be able to run these
things concurrently.
I want to be able to run the
backend and run the frontend.
And because of that they need
to run on different ports.
So in my backend
config file, I've
configured the thing
to run on port 8082.
In the frontend config
file, I haven't specified
what port I wanted to run on.
So by default it'll
run on port 8080.
So now when I start these things
up, the backend is on 8082.
The frontend is on 8080, and
the value of backend.URL is what
you see in this config file--
localhost 8082.
So the config file on the right
is in the frontend project.
And that's the frontend
project being told
where the backend service is.
The backend service
is on localhost 8082.
And that works fine in my
development environment.
But what about when
I deploy this to GCP?
My backend service
is not going to be
running on local host 8082.
It's going to be
running someplace else.
So these are the
config files that I
would have in my project
that support my development
environment.
In addition to those
application .yml files,
you can have config files with
names like application-GCP.yml.
Now that -GCP means something
special to Micronaut.
So these config
files will only be
loaded if the application
is running on GCP.
So if I run these applications
in my development environment,
these configure are in place.
When I build those applications
and deploy them to GCP,
these configs are
in place in addition
to the application.yml
configs, and these settings
take precedence.
So in the backend service, I've
got application-GCP configured
so the service runs
on port 8080, Which
would be the default
value had I not changed
that in the config
file there on the left.
Remember I set that to 8020 for
the benefit of my development
environment.
When I deploy to GCP,
I want that service
to run on port 8080 so I've
got a supporting config there.
And likewise in
the frontend, when
I'm running on GCP that's where
the backend service is running
is that URL that you see there.
So instead of looking
at local host 8082,
we're looking at the
URL you see there.
That's where the frontend
will be making calls
to to get data from the backend.
And this is one small example
of support in the framework
specifically targeted at GCP.
And here I'm just configuring
a port number and a URL.
But all of your
application config--
any of your
application config that
needs to be different in
the cloud environment,
GCP cloud environment
in particular,
we provided a place for
you to put those configs.
So now I'm ready to publish
these applications to GCP.
And so I've got a
couple of app.yml files.
The URL down there at
the bottom gives you
the full reference
for all the things you
can do in these app.yml files.
I've kept these
really, really simple.
So on the left is
the backend service.
On the right is the
frontend service,
and I think they're
configured exactly the same
except for the service names.
So I've got some auto
scaling in place there.
We can configure how much
RAM is being allocated
each of these environments.
But I've got config files
for both the services is
what's relevant there.
And now, one of the last
pieces is one of the ways
to deploy Micronaut
services to GCP
is you can use Google's App
Engine Gradle plugin, which is
really, really simple to use.
So I add it to the class
pass of the build script
as you see up in the upper
left, apply the plugin.
And then down at
the bottom left,
you see where I'm configuring
some things that the App Engine
plug-in needs.
So in particular,
I have to specify,
where is the JAR file
that is the application
that I want to deploy?
When I run the deploy, I want
to stop the previous version.
I want to promote the new
one to automatically become
the main one.
And project OCI
Micronaut, that's
just the name of
the project where
I'm deploying these things.
So if I were to execute the
App Engine deploy Gradle
task, the command
you see on the right
there that's literally
what I would type in
to deploy this service to GCP.
In fact, that is what I
typed in at the beginning
of the presentation to
deploy a new version
of our backend service to GCP.
So I've added just
a few lines of code
to the build.gradle file,
executed a Gradle command,
and that service has
been deployed to GCP.
And we'll get back to
that in a little bit.
We'll see the new version of the
service responding to requests.
But again, what I
wanted to point out here
is how easy it is to deploy
Micronaut services to GCP--
just a few lines in
your build.gradle file.
Sort of roughly a
similar amount of code
would be involved in doing
the same thing with Maven.
Micronaut has great support
for both Gradle and Maven.
Really you can use any
build tool that you like.
But we've made it very, very
easy to deploy applications
to GCP.
One more example of
GCP specific config
is in addition to
application.yml,
you can express your
Micronaut config
in an executable Groovy code.
And now you can have arbitrary
logic in your config file
for generating config values.
And in particular case, reaching
out to Google's metadata
server to grab some
secrets about my database
URL, my database user
name, my database password.
So this is code that I can
commit to source code control.
There's no passwords.
There's no secrets here.
This code only gets evaluated
when the application's
running on GCP.
And when the application
is running on GCP,
I'm getting all my
database credentials
from the metadata server there.
You've got a lot of
flexibility there.
Micronaut is great
really as a component
of many parts of your
application architecture.
So the easy one to think
about is microservices.
People build microservices,
they deploy them to GCP,
and Micronaut is
terrific for that.
But Micronaut is
also a great fit
for certain kinds
of edge devices.
So I've got a bunch
of Raspberry Pis
here that, in just
a minute, I'll
spend a couple of
minutes talking
about what's going on there.
But we've got Micronaut services
running on these Raspberry Pis,
doing some interesting things.
I have Micronaut code
running on an Android phone.
So I've got a Google
Pixel 3, and I've
got some microservices
deployed to GCP.
I've got Micronaut
application running
on my phone, a native app
running on the phone, built
with Micronaut that's making
calls to those GCP services.
These particular edge devices
are not making calls to GCP,
but they very well could.
We've got really, really
great integration support
in Micronaut for participating
in a number of areas
of your architecture.
So it could be the case that
you've got Micronaut apps
running on your edge devices.
You've got Micronaut
services running
in your cloud environment.
You can have Micronaut apps
running on mobile devices.
And there are attributes
of the framework
that make it a really,
really compelling
in all those environments.
And I'm going to
press on here and try
to get straight to some demos.
So if we could switch
back to the demo machine,
that would be helpful.
There we go.
So that's a picture-- for
those of you who are far away
and can't really see, that's
a picture of this thing.
So what I've got is I've
got four Raspberry Pi
Zeros, and two Raspberry
Pi 3s, and we're
going to see a diagram
that will tell us
a little bit about what's
going on in that environment.
Can we switch to my
demo machine, please.
There it is.
All right.
Very good.
So what I want to do is--
I apologize.
Could we go back to the
slide one for one minute?
There's a slide there
that I want to look at.
And I appreciate the patience
of the AV folks there.
There we go.
Sorry about that.
So this diagram
represents what's
going on the Raspberry Pis.
So we've got an SPA
frontend that we'll
see in just a minute.
It's very, very simple.
It's making requests to some
Micronaut service called
the home controller
that's running
on one of these Raspberry Pis.
And we've got four
other Raspberry
Pis that are all running
copies of the same service,
and those services
are all communicating
with the database.
So SPA talking to kind
of a gateway service,
that gateway service
is communicating
to a number of services
on the backend,
and those backend
services are communicating
with the database.
If we go back to the
demo machine again
I would appreciate that.
All right.
I need to get connected
to that network.
All right.
Now, if I refresh this page.
So this is the SPA
application, and the data
that's being represented there
is not terribly interesting.
It's just a list
of company names.
you'll see OCI, Moog,
and Tesla there.
This is really the
interesting part, the part
that I want to focus on.
And notice that green box,
the four small Raspberry Pis
are called mnpi1,
mnpi2, mnpi3, and mnpi4.
And in the UI I can tell
which of those devices
handled a particular request.
So as I reload this page
over and over and over again,
we're round robining through
all of those backend services.
So on that diagram where you
saw four company services,
were round robining through
all of those services.
And what I'm going
to do right now
is I just unplugged one of them.
So I unplug mnpi1.
So now 2, 3, and 4
are still operational.
But pi1 is down for
maintenance or it's crashed
or for whatever reason, it's
not operational right now.
And I'm able to do that
without interrupting
the rest of the system.
So I'm still round robining
through the other devices.
That request was
handled by number four.
That request was handled
by number two, then three,
and then four.
So we just took this
guy out of the mix
and the rest of the
system continues
to behave as we would hope.
And I want to look at a
little bit of the code that's
involved in making that happen.
So if I were to--
and I'm going to do this
really pretty quickly.
This is the HTTP client that's
being used in the frontend
to communicate with the backend.
And notice on line 12 there
where the client annotation
is, is the word companies.
What's happened is all
four of the company
services have started up
and registered themselves
with Consul, our service
discovery engine that's
running on one of the devices.
So on the frontend, when
I want to communicate
with those devices, I've
annotated this interface
with @clientcompanies.
And what will happen when
this client is initialized
is Micronaut will reach out to
the service discovery engine
and find, where are all
the company services.
So it discovers these four
Raspberry Pis dynamically,
and it's round
robining through them--
doing client side load
bouncing to round robin
through all those devices.
And then when one
of them disappears,
the round robining just skips
over, 1, 2, 4, 1, 2, 4, 1, 2,
4, if number three
is out of the mix.
And I don't have to write any
of that code in the application
to take advantage of that.
So here in my home controller,
this is in the frontend.
That's the call to the backend.
There's no code here
related to round robining.
related to retry logic.
I'm just saying, go
get the companies
from the backend service.
And all of the
complexity and stuff
that it takes to
make that happen
is all handled inside
of this HTTP client.
So the client side
load balancing
is built into this client.
The retry logic is
built into the client.
And now my application code
is kept very, very simple.
And it's very, very easy
to take advantage of or get
to send communications
to whatever is happening
in that backend service.
I hope all that makes sense.
I need to get back on
the public network now--
Google Next 2019, there we go.
All right.
So you see the
commands there that I
executed at the
beginning of the session.
And now, if I go back
to the backend again,
now we see Google Next
says, hello, Jeff.
That's evidence that
we're communicating
with the version of the
service that I deployed
at the beginning of this talk.
And then if I go to send
a request to the frontend,
we'll see that the frontend is
communicating with that updated
instance of the backend.
So at the beginning
of the session
I made a trivial code change
and deployed a new version
of the service to GCP.
And what it took to
deploy that service to GCP
is basically the
Gradle config that you
saw in the slides earlier.
Take just a super
quick look at that.
All right.
So here's my backend project.
In my build.gradle file,
I've got the App Engine
plugin added to the class path.
I'm applying the plug-in here.
And down here
somewhere, right here
is the code that
tells the plug-in what
to do when I ask it to
deploy this service to GCP.
You've seen all of the
complexity involved
in deploying the
Micronaut services to GCP.
This is all of it.
There's no pieces that I'm
doing any hand waving over.
So it's very, very
simple to build
and deploy Micronaut services
to GCP is the bottom line.
[MUSIC PLAYING]